[Music]
a big monday night football game tonight
as the raiders headed to socal to take
on the chargers can't wait for the game
we know raider nation travels well chris
matthews he's there joining us from so
far tonight and chris the raiders will
definitely feel the las vegas support
i'll tell you what here at sofi stadium
this afternoon probably ten to one
raider fans as they make their way
inside the stadium here raider nation of
course is a global brand you can find
raider nation fans in all corners of
this earth and they are loud and proud
one thing about raider nation down here
in southern california though kind of a
little different in fact it was hall of
famer and former raider tim brown who
said raider nation in southern
california is kind of a different breed
[Music]
[Applause]
it is definitely a different breed down
here all the fans from back when when
the raiders were in la they're still
here they still thrive and we're just
all coming back it's kind of like a
family reunion we're all coming back
home a little bit it's a variety of
people here i mean you got every
ethnicity every walk of life from movie
stars to to homeless we all love that
silver and black herbert's heart
we already getting to put it on the
grill let's go let's go just cook baby
just cook cooking up that w go raiders
baby let's go get that win baby
[Music]
all right so once again raider nation
showing up in force inside sophie
stadium there will be a lot of silver
and black fans you can see right now
this is kind of like toshiba plaza right
here where fans kind of congregate
before they go into the stadium but as
you can see as you look around oh yeah
not many blue jerseys but lots of silver
and black reporting live from right
outside so five stadium i'm chris
matthews eight sports now we are live
local now